when you first began writing the 13th
continuum was it in your mind to turn
this into a film to turn this into a
series or did this come in incremental
steps yeah it was in my mind from the
beginning for sure that it had to be a
trilogy the story once it started to
take shape in my mind was so epic and
sweeping and involved multiple different
environments that I kind of felt
strongly that I needed to be a series
and also that I wanted to play the long
game a little bit with the series which
means that certain reveals don't happen
even till second or third book which is
a little bit risky actually because it's
harder to land a deal for multiple books
all at once
also my main protagonist like they kind
of aren't really meeting in person until
the second book and quite into it so
that that was a big risk I took but I
took it because I really believed in the
story I was telling in terms of the film
aspect I do write very visually and I do
write in a way that is pretty adaptable
and this series in particular because
it's big world building science fiction
with teen protagonists Hollywood has
changed a lot especially even since I
started working in it and so the types
of films they make are become more
narrow but this slots right into what
they still make which is the big genre
of films that could be a temple so
that's one of the reasons why we feel
that this could be appropriate for film
even though you know TV is still on the
table because TV is such a rich
landscape right now and lots of books
are being adapted into television shows
so you're seeing kind of this real shift
and where people are viewing and
consuming content we're kind of in a
very changing time I call it the wild
wild west of media publishing so we'll
see what comes to pass how much did you
working in film previously coming to LA
having that as your degree helped in
seeing the bigger picture that if you
had really started out with say an MFA
and writing or something maybe would
have made it more myopic yeah it would I
mean I think MFA and
went back and forth a lot about whether
or not I needed one at a certain point
in my life and they're very expensive
typically yes there are some that are
funded those are incredibly difficult to
get into but for the most part you're
gonna be going into debt you know most
authors do and then being an author
isn't typically that lucrative for a
variety of reasons so you kind of end up
in a hole and you know a lot of people
MFA's end up teaching that kind of ends
up being what their job is and if you
teach too much it can be hard to write
your own work the other thing you
happens with MFA is they they largely
teach too short story which not many
people read short stories is not that's
why you see a lot of people coming out
as programs might publish a short story
collection right off the bat if they're
lucky and then also they tend not to be
so welcoming to young adult writers and
also to people who are at genre like
myself there are exceptions to that
Hollins College has a great program for
children's writers I believe Vermont
College of Fine Arts has a great program
but for the most part we are not really
going to be getting into the Iowa
Writers Workshop so it's a little bit of
a different process but I think also not
having that I think something with MFA
it's a little intimidating they come out
of school and they're like oh my gosh I
have to write like you know like these
grain of these great authors and you
know as opposed to just really
developing what you want to write in
your story the film background was
interesting because I think it did shape
how I consume and understand stories and
also I write very structurally and very
visually because a lot of my job was
working on screenplays with writers and
I worked on a lot to add up patients and
screenplays are incredibly structural
first act second act midpoint break
third act and they really have to slot
into a certain page count to even really
be considered so I really kind of look
at structure a lot when I'm writing a
novel and I think about that a lot and I
think you know there is a lot of
translation between the way these
stories are told what do you plan is the
process once you've finished the third
book which will be in May of next year
you're looking for a writer director yes
a writer and or director I mean
sometimes a writer director in my
experience working in development
having a director who has a vision for
how they want to translate something to
screen is the single most important
aspect of any moviemaking it's the
single most determining aspect of
whether the film will be any good it's
always the filmmaker
yes screenwriters matter of course they
matter but they're not the ultimate
architects of the film it really is the
director so that's kind of the
difference between novels and movies is
that you know you write a script it's
gonna go through a lot of filters a lot
of hands a lot of lenses often a lot of
writers usually the person who writes
the first draft of the script or the
first drafts often is not the person
that writes through the movie going into
production a lot of times there's
multiple writers so what I really would
like is to find a director that really
gets it and has a vision for how it
should be told as a film and is willing
to take creative license to really adapt
it well because a lot of times what
works in a book isn't gonna work as well
on-screen and there's a lot of
world-building that gets opened up in
the second and third books and so some
of that might need to go into the first
movie so I'm just kind of looking at it
and I am open to adapting it myself but
I actually would prefer to have someone
else come in and do it because I think
it's very difficult for authors we're so
close to our material to have
perspective to really do a good job with
the screenplay I think it's better
sometimes to have someone with an
outside our set of eyes to come in and
really kind of shape the material so
yeah so we're kind of out to different
writers and directors I'm looking for
someone to come in and I just want that
meeting where it's like someone who has
the passion and the vision and that's
what I'm looking for I'm not in a rush
to do a deal with someone it doesn't
feel right so I just want to do it in a
way that feels good and where we're
gonna do something great that's
interesting that you that you actually
want to hand it off to someone else do
you think that from your prior working
that you saw too many people that were
close with great intentions and it
didn't turn out yes I think that's
pretty accurate and even now even just
as a consumer when I go to see films
there are certain books that have been
adapted by the authors and a lot of the
time I think they might have been
feted from someone else coming in and I
don't know if that's a popular opinion
or not but gone girl is a good example I
actually think that that might have
benefitted from someone else really
working on that script I mean you can't
say it's all hypothetical but yeah
that's part of it and it's also like
from his spend time I would almost
rather spend time writing additional
books as opposed to working on a
screenplay where there's going to be a
lot of notes a lot of changes and
ultimately I'm not the architect of it
yeah and it's also a little bit of you
know I'm not in a rush to get this done
in a way that doesn't feel right I've
been in development and I've seen it for
so long and it makes me more realistic
about the process like a lot of people
think oh my god I got an option deal or
I got this and like now I'm gonna be at
the premiere and like oh my gosh that
does not at all mean your movies gonna
be made and even if it is it could be so
long from now you know it's a long
process and also you're looking at a big
budget like that's the other thing that
happens with the kind of stuff that I'm
writing it can't be made for a low
budget right we're talking something 60
to 80 million at the minimum so that
requires a huge investment on someone's
part if you think about it so I'm just
much more realistic about the process
because of my experience
you